This week Council held its monthly meeting
for May.
After receiving a verbal submission on the
Long Term Plan from local resident, Mr. Robert
Johnston, the council moved into receiving
reports.
First up, was a regeneration report on proposed
dredging in the Kaiapoi River.
The Council authorised staff to proceed with
design, consenting and work programming of
dredging that will increase navigability along
the Kaiapoi River, particularly at low tide.
Dredging is also planned for the north side
of the river near the William Street Bridge.
This will allow for the installation of floating
pontoons alongside the Riverview terraces
that are currently under construction.
Council approved the design and layout of
the pontoons and staff will now put the purchase
of the pontoons themselves out to tender.
The Council also expressed its support for
Environment Canterbury’s plans to fill gaps
in the secondary stop bank along the Ashley
River.
As part of this work, ECAN will be raising
both Cones Road & Milton Road approximately
3 metres and that work is expected to take place
later this year.
Although traffic diversions will be in place
during the road works, access to nearby facilities
such as the Dog Park and BMX track will be
maintained, as well as access to the Ashley
Bridge itself.
The project will be fully funded by Environment
Canterbury.
Following community consultation, the Waimakariri
District Council Stormwater Drainage and Watercourse
Protection Bylaw 2018 was adopted.
The bylaw has a range of provisions that aim
to protect our storm water and drainage infrastructure,
mitigate flooding hazards and safeguard the
environment against the discharging of contaminants.
It also makes clearer to landowners their
responsibilities around drains and waterways.
The Council also approved a draft submission
to the upcoming Government Policy Statement
on Land Transport.
This submission is seen as an important opportunity
for the Council to present its views about
the new Government’s proposals for priorities
and investment in land transport.
In our submission we expressed our support
for more public transport options for the
Greater Christchurch area and we strongly
advocated for the continuation of the proposed
NZTA Woodend Bypass.
The next monthly Council meeting will be at
the Council Chambers in Rangiora on Tuesday
5th of June at 1pm.